how many people here have internet
connectivity how many people don't gosh
okay well I don't I don't know if I got
here too late i rebooted my computer and
I still can't get on the network so
rather than try to move ahead I typed in
the URL here for the repo in that the
notebooks that I've created for this are
I was going to show you what those look
like but I can't get to the internet so
you should see a list of files there
that looks something like that so I'll
keep over now there's going to be I
apologize for the makeshift nature of
this but everything I tried to connect
to the internet failed so anyone not yet
connected or able to access that URL is
github.com slash gumption slash pi data
- simpsons raise your hand if you
haven't gotten there okay
when you get there I recommend that you
open up the notebook that has clean in
capital letters PI data tutorial
Simpsons clean IP ynb notebook actually
you'll need to you'll need to grab the
notebooks and then open them up but this
is the one that I'll be driving the
presentation from is the clean notebook
anyone not able to access the URL to
repeal
and you went up there yet okay I've also
created some additional files there for
those who don't have everything
installed already there's a there's an
HTML version so in the worst case if
you're not able to get the notebook and
get it all set up then you can at least
follow along through an HTML version in
a browser you want to see if I can
connect on this one
[Applause]
you'll see if I can get on this just in
case
Oh weird alright
[Music]
for some reason I'm allowed oops I can
get on this notebook
let me try again here
[Applause]
all right well
[Applause]
well I'm not quite sure how how to run
this I've got a spare notebook here that
I seem to be able to access so I guess
okay so is everyone there at the
depository okay if you cloned repository
and you you set it up somewhere on your
computer then I'm going to just still
drive it from my other laptop here but
that's what you should see and then as I
said if you if you can't if you have
trouble downloading you can still whoops
darn okay so you have to you'll have to
download that file as well in order to
be able to render it okay I'm going to
jump back over this one
okay so I apologize for the rather slow
start here I I'm delighted to hear be
here my name is Joe McCarthy and I am a
data scientist with indeed I help people
get jobs and sometimes I help people
learn something about Python and data
analysis indeed is a sponsor for this
conference so I hope you'll stop by and
see us at the booth as I suspect many of
the people presenting here at the
conference or maybe organizations that
are sponsoring or otherwise
participating we have we are hiring
people who know Python in data science
and so on we're also giving away a drone
raffling off a drone so if you stop by
our booth sometime during the conference
will be raffling that off I think at
lunchtime on Friday so can everyone read
this or do I need to increase the font
further in the back can you read it okay
great so I proposed this tutorial for a
variety of motivations one is that I I
have unevenly spaced opportunities to do
unevenly spaced time series data
analysis it
I don't do it often enough so that oh
yeah I know - I know right what to do I
need to go find whatever notebook I was
using in order to open it up up and
figure out oh yeah those are the
techniques I was using so I thought I
would create a notebook that would serve
as sort of a prototypical example of
that and since I was going to create
such a notebook I figured I would share
it as well another motivation is that
the last time I went searching for a
notebook that had some of the utilities
I use I encountered a fairly new website
called data dot world
has anyone heard of data dot world
before oh okay
couple people good so I so I thought
that you know in the process I would
introduce you to data dot world as well
and essentially data dot world is sort
of like github for data it lets you
create data repositories different
people can contribute to them that you
can have discussions on it it's really
collaborating around data and yeah
because I can't get to the network from
my laptop I won't show you there but
there are there are links there for
those who want to explore a little bit
about it
so I I was also inspired by a tutorial
by Josh Devlin called turbocharge your
data acquisition using the data world
Python library and I've actually
borrowed liberally from Josh's online
tutorial because he provides a nice
introduction to just some of the things
here actually without a notebook yeah I
have a locally cached copy since they
help you ok and then the other thing and
I'm so far not doing so well at this did
anyone happen the where they went at PI
data 2015 in Seattle
ok now many anyone go to my tutorial
good ok yeah so if you think this was a
slow start you should have seen that one
I gave a tutorial on Python for data
and didn't provide enough information
ahead of time about what people who
download install so it took quite some
time to get off the ground and I'm
hoping we won't experience too much of
that this time but unfortunately since I
don't have a network I'm going to be
somewhat limited my ability to follow
along and help although there might be
other people here who might be able to
help if people have trouble so anyhow
what happened in that tutorial is I had
a tutorial I already prepared I spent
weeks preparing and given internally to
at the company I was working for at the
time and I ended up trying to squeeze
that all into a two-hour slot and it was
not very successful so I ended up
rushing through it all not getting it to
everything and I didn't want to have
that happen so this time I started out
with a smaller topic but then it grew so
we'll talk about some of that but but
the main focus here is on using pandas
for doing data analysis and it turns out
so how many people here consider
themselves experts in pandas ok I'm not
raising my hand either how many people
here consider themselves
intermediate-level pandas ok how many
people here are somewhat more a beginner
at pandas ok I have I've included a
number of links throughout this notebook
to various documentation that might help
of those who are at the beginning or
intermediate level even to to learn more
about it so mainly what we're going to
be doing is looking at data world and
unfortunately we'll be using just the
stuff from data world I put in this
notebook but you can look around and
browse yourself and then we're going to
go into a little bit about data cleaning
my experience in using almost any data
sets is never as clean as I expect it to
be even after I've cleaned it and so I
actually have a whole nother notebook
about data cleaning for this stuff that
people here are interested in data
cleaning ok so I'm going to do is
reserve that for the end what I did but
there's a Python script in here called
something like clean Simpsons data or
something like that that
just magically you know do as much
cleaning as possible and that there's
time at the end and people were
interested I can go over a little bit
about what I did to try to do that but
it's more than norm the exception that
the data isn't as clean as I'd like okay
so at this point I'm hoping that you
have installed anaconda and how many
people don't have anaconda installed oh
good okay lots of hands went up the last
tutorial I'm going to say a little bit
here about Python 2 & 3 only that I
still use Python 2 because that's the
version of Python that we're using at
indeed how many people here use Python 3
and how many use Python 2 okay so I've
set this up so that you shouldn't be
able to run this notebook whether using
Python 2 or Python 3 okay and I'm not
going to go in a lot of details here but
just the only thing that you need to do
in order to if you're running Python 2
to be able to use this notebook is to
import the print function and while
you're at it or while I'm at I like to
import the division function as well and
then that pretty much takes here any of
the compatibility issues that come into
play in this notebook okay so how many
people how many froggy people is the
first time using a jupiter notebook okay
good
so you know how to all rerun things so
I'm going to just kind of go through
here and import the usual aliases pandas
aliasing and SPD numpy as NP and then
matplotlib pipe lot as PLT and then what
I want is for any graphs that we create
to show up in the in the cell itself
okay so I'm not going to go through this
in any great detail I just actually gave
a tutorial at indeed to product managers
kind of give trying to get them up to
speed on Python and
and panda so I'm not going to go into a
lot of details here but the basic
there's some information here about the
basics of pandas for anyone who's
relatively new to it it's a tab view or
two-dimensional data structure that can
be manipulated with Python commands the
columns in the data where the domain
data structure will be using as a data
frame which is the table the columns are
sometimes called series we can access
them using a variety of mechanisms
included including slice operators other
concepts that we'll be drawing on in
this tutorial are grouping the the
paradigm of split apply and combined and
then merging data sets as well okay so
ordinarily I would click on this link
and show you the turbo charge your data
acquisition using data world Python
library and or the Python SDKs
documentation and/or the data wrangling
tutorial but you'll have to click on
those yourself or these those of you who
have internet access so in order to
install the data world library if you
have
kondeh you can do kondeh install - see
Conda - Forge data world - PI has anyone
done that yet okay has it worked ok so
if you pop over your command window
okay so you would just type in what I
say it was alright you know it's got
copy and paste it
Oh actually I guess their fight a lot
people here don't have max to so
whatever your your preferred terminal
window is so you just type that into the
command line and and run it and that
should do the installation for you is
that as they would not be able to do
that
okay then I'm going to pass it on
luckily I borrowed a screenshot from
from Josh and you once you they would
not create a data world account yet okay
so you might want to take this moment to
go out to data dot world and create an
account for yourself let me just see if
this this doesn't come back yeah all
right
and once you go to that account you
should be able to go to your settings
and then click on the Advanced tab and
get a API token
and you want having any trouble with
doing that
okay whoops
once you've got your API token
the next thing you'll do is type in DW
configure and it should bring up
something like that and then you just
copy and paste the token from that
window right there
oops
okay
how many people have gotten that far so
far good alright people need little more
time okay
always our myth bring one who's gotten
that far the next thing you would do is
do pip install data dot world and then
in brackets just like that just copy and
paste that line into your into your
terminal window
okay I'm going to continue on here there
is the HTML file there if if you get too
bogged down on this so I end up doing
this time serious analysis and other
kinds of various analyses in pandas on a
daily basis not so much even we space
time series analysis on a variety of
types of data that indeed uses but I
thought it would be more interesting if
instead of looking at indeed data for
this tutorial we would look at something
that's a little more generally
accessible and well known so the
simpsons is a TV show that's been around
for quite some time it is a let's see
here there were some things is the
longest running American sitcom and the
longest running American animated
program so and amazing I'm assuming most
people have at least heard of it if not
watched it the data set for this episode
is for the Simpsons was actually gotten
through several steps and I was going to
walk you through some of those but they
originally straight for one person's
tutorial who then made available for get
github and then it was used by a casual
user and then eventually it was uploaded
to dated Outworld okay and essentially
there are four data files data world
essentially allows you to host CSV files
and the four files there have to do with
the Simpsons characters the episodes the
locations and the script lines we're
only going to be using the episodes and
script lines and for the purposes of
this tutorial so the first thing to do
after you have installed the data world
panda's library Howey people have
finished installing that great okay is
to then import it and then the
convention for data world is to import
it aliasing it as
w so the reso there's a few cells here
in the notebook that are taken directly
out of josh's tutorial with permission
and what happens is when you actually
load the dataset it will create a
locally cached copy of the files
associated with the data set in a
directory in your home drive dot DW okay
so if you use the optional force update
equals true option you'll say go get the
data from data world and get the
freshest data I've already got locally
cached so I would I would encourage you
to run this now it might take a couple
of minutes actually uh go fetch the data
and and upload it now I have I'm hoping
this will still work
I'm going to give it a few more minutes
I don't know what will happen I think
what it does it goes to see if there's
anything new on the server but I haven't
thought about the fit okay well I may
have to actually switch over to my other
laptop after all
although actually I use yours Alex
fortunately one of my colleagues has
this installed on his laptop so if you
excuse me for a minute here
I bailed on a laptop he refused office
also everyone's you want to hear it or
something okay thank you
and then that's the password for that
one so okay
okay so
ah thank you Oh actually
it came back let me see if it actually
nope okay so
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh alex has yes your scroll your
scrolling is in the opposite direction
of mine okay so I'm going to quickly
rerun the selves
okay has everyone gotten to this stage
all right so you can see that there's a
cache of the CSV files you can see the
script lines file is much larger than
the others and we're now going to start
we're going to end a little bit of time
just looking at the data and then we'll
start doing some analysis
okay so there's lots of information
associated with the various data sets
I'm not going to go through it all the
main thing that we care about here since
we're using pandas is that we have let's
see here there's information about each
of the each of these files and there's
actually the most recent version as well
as the original version and you can
explore that on your own the main thing
we care about is there's an attribute of
data frames the data in a data world
repository essentially is available in
three different formats data frames
tables which are essentially lists and
the raw data itself and we're only going
to be focusing on data frames I'll also
note that data world has lots of other
things I'm not going to be talking about
they have their own version of SQL
called DW SQL F Sparkle they have a
number of capabilities for actually
querying the data directly from data
world if you have very large data sets
you don't want to try to copy to your
disk
but we're not going to go into that
because this is a PI data conference and
we're mostly interested in pandas here
okay so if you then run the very you if
you then loop through the different LDS
attributes data frames tables and raw
data you'll get a little more
information about them the main thing we
care about is the data frames attribute
that we're going to use throughout this
and so to try to simplify things I'm
just going to copy the data frame
associated with the CSV file
and some script lines into a variable
that I'm going to use just called EF the
first time you do this are you getting a
warning message when you just see that
okay
and I copied the warning message I got
here and right away it was like oh looks
like there's some noise in the data in a
particular what this is drawing our
attention to is that there's at least
three columns and actually more that
have mixed data types and whenever I see
that like oh there there might be a
problem here so to try to figure out
what's going on there one thing we can
look at is the pandas operator or
function info which will give us some
information about the objects or
different columns in the data frame and
we can see that there are a few that are
showing up as just object and that may
be somewhat problematic so one way that
I go about trying to diagnose this and
again I'm going to postpone or just you
know entirely thorough exploration of
data cleaning but I often like to see
what kinds of things are in these
columns and so what I do here is I'm
looping through and for each column
label I'm going to print out the number
of unique values the number of values
that are know and then the number of
data types by just running the pandas
apply function on the column label to
extract the type of each element and
then count the number of different types
of values of in this case the number of
different types so you can see here that
there are there's a couple things that
are coming up with two data types here
timestamp in milliseconds character ID
raw character text wall location text
spoken words normalized text and word
counts so and then another thing that I
sometimes do is then I want to see a
little more about what the distribution
of these values is
so you can see we have a number of
string and integer values here for
timestamp that's usually a warning sign
and many others are a combination of
strings and floats and it's often the
case of course that a string field if
it's not present will just have the the
na n value the null value for for pandas
so those are somewhat understandable so
again I'm not going to spend a lot of
time going through the data cleaning
there's a separate notebook I have here
ironically it's not very cleaned up that
that will that you can look it through
or that will go through at the end of
there's time so here's the head of the
data frame each row in the data frame
has an identifier the identifier is
unique identifier for this script line
there is an episode identifier which is
a number starting at one number is the
number of the line within the episode
okay so each time you have a new episode
number is going to be reset to one the
raw text is the text that was extracted
directly from the rep the web scraper
and actually the the problems are with
the data noise are mostly caused by
quotation marks and various unexpected
places that that the vyas the reading in
the csv file the pandas has trouble with
the timestamp in milliseconds i actually
meant to go and look into this a little
more I think it's actually the timestamp
in milliseconds since the beginning of
the season so if there's time thing we
can look at that
there's a there's an indication of
whether it's a speaking line uh there is
you know I should do is let me just
print the columns here that would
probably make things simpler
there's a boolean indicating whether or
not it's a speaking line because there
are other kinds of lines such as you
know stage directions or you know sort
of parenthetical comments about what's
going on if you if you look at scripts
there is a character ID a location ID
and then the text the raw text
associated with each character in each
ID it turns out that the character ID
uniquely identifies a character but
characters can have different flavors
right so you can have Homer you can have
young Homer you can have you know
Homer's thoughts you can have a variety
of sort of slight variants that they're
all kind of about Homer but they're not
strictly speaking home or perhaps at
least in the script and locations can
also have multivalued there can be more
than one location text associated with a
given location the spoken words are
let's see if I can show you some
examples here
the spoken word so essentially each
script line has a character : and then
whatever the character says if anything
so if you strip off the character text
then you get the raw character text
field and then the spoken words is
whatever comes after the : okay and the
normalized text is essentially a
lowercase version with most of the
punctuation but not all which is another
source of problems removed from the
remaining the actual the Texas spoken
and then last field is a word count
field that indicates the number of words
in that normalized text field okay so
rather than go belabor how to clean up
the data if you just import the PI data
Simpsons module that I included in that
repository and then run PI data or phi
beta underscore simpson's clean simpson
script lines it's a very specialized
function that ought not to be used
naylor context and sign terribly
well-documented at this point but I'll
update throughout posit or later you
should get a new data frame that's
cleaned up a bit okay
among the things that I that did was
that there were some lines that had
values in the wrong fields so there was
one case where for example one of the
timestamp in milliseconds was
Springfield Elementary School and again
it was because the quotation marks
weren't parsed and everything got
shifted and then it also converts
everything to that are integers to int
is euro for character ID and location ID
the null value so we have int that I
just I just find it easier than having a
mix of floats and na n the speaking
lines had a mix of strings and actual
boolean values and then the perhaps the
most important thing that you realized
early on was if you actually look at the
the ordering here the first row in this
data frame is actually not the first
episode or the first number or a not
death so I
sorted them all by ID which now gives us
the script line sorted in the order in
which they occurred through the entire
course of The Simpsons history
represented by the data spot okay for
some of this the the work that we're
going to do it turns out that the season
is valuable and the season of each
episode is not included in the script
lines but it is included in the episodes
so we're not going to do any data
cleaning or any exploration of the
episodes data except to note that it's
got this season value and fortunately
the values are all integers so we don't
have to really worry about that one and
I'm not going to go into all this but
there you can see some of the data in
there so we're going to just the only
thing we really need is season and so
what I'm going to do is merge the data
frame that we got some script lines and
the data frame from episodes but again
since I only care about the episode the
columns that the season column I'm going
to grab that but it turns out the ID
field in the episodes data maps to the
episode ID in the main data frame that
we're using the script lines and so I'm
going to retain the ID here for the ID
column for the merge how many people
have used the merge operation before
okay so the merge is kind of like it's
joining together it doesn't saying merge
these two data frames and the left on
says use the column in the left data
frame in this case DF that's called
episode ID and map it to the column in
the right data frame in this case DF
episodes called ID it's going to do a
left join so it's going to preserve all
the rows that were originally in the DF
and just populate the season values
wherever it finds them okay and then I
just use a little trick here where the
suffix is if so now we're going to have
to ID fields right because the
script lines has an ID for the actual
line and there's an ID in the episodes
for the episode ID so now we have to ID
fields I'm going to say the one the left
will retain there'll be no extra suffix
the one the right will have an
underscore Y which is the default value
actually if you didn't specify suffixes
and I'm just going to drop the ID Y
value because we already have the
episode ID in the original data frame
I'd rather call it episode ID is an ID X
or ie Y the other thing though is that
season now well here I'll show you
season is all the way over on the right
which you know is fine I guess
but class ly to me season should be
somewhere on the left you know closer to
where the episode IDs are and so that's
relatively easy to accomplish this by
simply renaming the column or reordering
the columns by just specifying a
different order here so what I've done
is I've essentially I grabbed the column
values I copied them into here and
specified them moving season from the
end to the second position and now when
I look at the data frame we get the
season right there okay questions yes
like what the wrong character screen or
the quick-draw location tax
sure so the script lines that this was
straight from had each line and if
you've seen a scripted says you know
character ID or character name : and
then something the character says so in
the scraping what the what the person
did originally is they wrote something
to split the line where the colon is
take whatever is the left of the colon
and put that in the raw character text
field and take whatever to the right of
that colon is and put it in the spoken
words and then whatever going through
the spoken words we it was then lower
case and the punctuation is removed to
come up with a normalized version which
is called normalized text other
questions in the damn yes oh do you have
any recollection so Conda update pandas
where he got a warning I got an
exception with the saner and the finding
climbing values and funny mixed values
in column with something
yes
down right there so if you're going to
warning you're fine but I got it thank
you I'm glad you free that out
other questions
okay
where I think I left off here
okay so time series analysis is
essentially analyzing data that has a
time element and usually the data is
collected based on evenly spaced time
increments so per day per week per
episode per season those kinds of things
and so we're going to start off here
with just some simple time series data
and analysis on the simpsons oh I
thought I had put this somewhere I guess
I should have put this up further on
anyhow there's a there's a sort of
summary description of the fields in the
data frame that we're using that was
extracted from The Simpsons script line
Steve CSV in case I overlooked anything
or wasn't clear about that each data
point in the in the Simpsons data has a
timestamp but also it kind of represents
a different element of time okay so you
can think about it as that that data
itself is sort of an unevenly spaced
data set all they won't go into too much
of that the episodes data each data
point is an episode your tonics
so a couple other things to note before
we start of manipulating it although
there are six hundred episodes in the
episode CSV on there are only 564
episode ID values in the script lines so
we're missing 36 episodes for which we
have no scripts and they seem to be
unevenly distributed as well so there's
a see here so we can say show me the
episodes for which the ID from GF
episodes is not using the not operator
here in the list of episode IDs in our
main data frame and that will show us
the 36 episodes let's see here
there we go so they seem to be scattered
among well actually I guess they seem to
be in the upper 500 mostly so we're just
going to ignore those since we don't
script lines and that's really our main
focus here okay so I want to make this a
little bit interactive at least although
there is another notebook with in big
caps answers out there in the repo so if
you want to peek ahead or you want to
leave early or whatever else happens
there are there's a separate notebook
there that has answers for all these
things but I thought it might be useful
to at least you know give you an
opportunity to do some some exercises
and pandas on our on our way there so
exercise aa1 I actually have four
different exercise sets here what are
the minimum maximum and mean number of
screep script lines per episode okay so
using the data we already have in the
data frame can you write the pandas
function that or a single pandas
function or series if you want to you
can break it down however you want that
will come up with the min Max and mean
number of script lines per episode and I
include some links there to some pandas
functions that you might find useful for
this task so I'll give you a minute or
two here to to think about that and try
a few things out perhaps
how many people have figured out okay
I'll give one minute and then we'll
start working through it a little bit of
time
okay so the first thing is we're talking
about per episode okay so because we
want to find out the something on a per
episode basis we're going to want to do
some grouping or at least that's the way
I would approach it if other people have
other solutions after I show you what I
how I would do it I'm eager to learn -
okay so I'm going to say DF group by
and then I'm going to say episode ID and
that's going to create a pandas group by
object which in itself is not terribly
readable and often not directly usable
as its on its own until we carve it up a
little bit okay so what we want to know
is the number of lines so what this
creates is a a group a group of rows
from the original data frame where are
actually a bunch of groups where each
group have the same episode ID okay so
now I've got I've got all these groups
of script lines organized by episode ID
and I'd like to find out how many there
are in each group okay so there's a two
a couple of different ways that we can
go about this one well here let me I'll
just create separate cells here as we
kind of go along here so you don't is we
can use the size operator okay and that
will essentially show me for every
episode ID the size of the group okay so
that's one way of doing it does anyone
know of another way okay if I use count
instead of size
pardon so counter also will will give me
the same number so if you so here let me
uh let me make this a little simpler by
just saying let's just grab the head so
it doesn't get so overwhelming and then
we can look at them both so size returns
a series a column essentially with with
the number of items in each group when
we call it after on a group by object
okay count essentially will also give me
the number but it sticks them in each of
the columns yes that's a good point so
the observation is that you know one of
the risks and we're doing this kind of
thing is that if we have rows with
nothing in them for example we could be
over counting and you're right and in
fact some of them have no lines there we
could restrict it to the spoken you know
only this ones with speaking lines and
there's there's a bunch of things we
could do to try to find out I think
that's a really important thing to keep
in mind we're going to conveniently
ignore that for now ah oh that's
interesting okay so yeah so let me first
show you how I was thinking about it and
then well then let me I'll expand it
then to the way you did it which i think
is an interesting idea because then
you're not depending on if you had if
you had lines missing from the data okay
so I would use a similar idea that is to
say
I can take the ID field so there's like
and then and then take the number of
unique values for that and again I'll do
head and then equivalently and just for
the benefit of people who are still kind
of learning about using pandas I the
exact same you know using dotted
notation I can just say dot ID as well
those are equivalent syntactic forms in
pandas so you're saying and I'm going to
stick with this one for now because the
notebook will highlight the strings that
help sort them out so you're saying take
the max number within that okay ah
that's interesting so why Oh number
starts at zero okay
the other one by the other one music
yeah
okay so the advantage of this one is
that if the CSV file itself was missing
some rows right and you had gaps in the
numbers then essentially assuming that
the numbers were correctly calculated to
begin with then this might get you a
more accurate reading so thanks other
other solutions
yeah yes I'm not I I could I'm trying to
keep it simple so the suggestion is here
we're including non-speaking lines here
ah okay so let me go back to my
preferred way only because I'm biased
there there's no reason why it's better
okay so the suggestion here is if we
want just restricted to and I'll put it
here so I don't forget if we want boots
to only speaking lines we can constrain
the rows that we look at and then
actually in this case we would want to
actually count the number of unique IDs
rather than the max number because this
would not allow us to do that okay so
how did you choose to constrain it
Pacific egg
okay I'm going to conveniently postpone
the AG thing up for a moment and just
say we the other way we can do this is
speaking line okay so what this does is
if I inside the brackets what I've done
here is I'm only returning the roads in
that data frame for which speaking line
is true okay so it's just one less thing
to introduce this point but okay I'm
sorry
oh because the normalized text when it's
not no okay it's a lower number
okay okay I'm going to keep it like this
something but I appreciate that
additional way of doing it because
actually I'm wondering what the if it's
a speaking line and there's no
normalized text I'm wondering if that's
you know point out yeah so long you'll
stay away from that for now but but
thanks out suggestion okay so now we
know a variety of ways of actually
figuring out what the number of speaking
lines are per episode so let me go back
up and let's just again take my favorite
prototypical example here if we take
this and then we want to know what's the
minimum number of speaking lines we can
use the min function whoops
oh right so I can now say take all of
those values that are returned the
different number of script lines on a
per episode basis and find me the
minimum number there
the end of the max function
and as you might know there's a mean
okay and it was noted earlier there's
actually ways if you're computing a
bunch of different statistics there are
ways of passing them into pandas and
computing them all once okay there's an
AG function that you can apply as well
so if these are the three functions I
care about then what I can do is call AG
and then pass in the names of the
functions strings and I'm going to do
meet min Mean Max because then that puts
me in the middle and get all three in a
series after after the tutorial or
sometime lately I will update with a new
notebook of whatever we create here
today in case you're having a hard time
following out okay well I think I'll
give you a moment here how many people
have done had used visualization
functions within pandas before okay
so essentially many of the capabilities
that you have in that plot Lib for
visualization are available directly as
methods you can apply to a data frame
okay and one of those is hist so
exercise a two here is to plot the
distribution of the number of script
lines per episode but now that we know
what the main the men mean and Max are
what does that distribution look like so
I'll give you a minute here
yes take an integer number huge entry
and then try to add an event over that
integer before it takes series and try
to navigate over that theory so this in
this case so do you have the latest
version of Conda of pandas installed
20.2 I think it's our up to if you do
Conda update pandas and it says you're
all set then you have the latest
otherwise it might be related is a I'm
off getting an error there huh it so
it's any unique and not unique could
that be a factor there's actually a
function unique and there's no one any
unique unique actually returns unique
values and any unique returns the number
of unique values integer so don't be
able to run this without dare okay who
has run this gotten an error and has the
latest version of conda's installed
after you have a panda's installed okay
okay note to self I should have made
quite explicit to get the latest version
of pandas installed yes
that work oh okay that's good to know
the describe function in older versions
of pandas at least will give you the
same capability there yet actually app
renting if you do condo update pandas
then you have to reload the library into
your notebook right so you'll have to so
if that's the case then what you should
probably do if you do con to it how many
people who had the problem with that
calling AG had an older version of
pandas okay so one way around it is you
can you can restart your kernel and then
after waited pausing a minute you can
run all above and we run everything up
to that point and that will include
reinstalling things we importing pandas
note how the release version hopefully
that will be an error okay so I will you
know I'm going to do I'm going to
actually go up here well no I will I'll
update that later cuz Nagato
did anyone do those steps so Khanda
update pandas restart kernel and rerun
all cells and did it not work okay good
thank you
okay so we left our heroes when they
were going to plot this I'm hoping you
don't need more time because this is
sort of a straightforward sort of a
thing you you either just plug it right
in or or you don't so I think I'm just
going to grab sort of our operating a
way of finding the number of unique
values and then just say dot hist
I'm having problems with that histah the
visualization self is another area
that's been under a lot of development
lately so there's more and more things
that are available directly as methods
versus doing the plot and then various
kinds and so on within pandas okay so a
little bit of a stretch here now that
you've know how to calculate the minimum
maximum and mean number of lines per
season or fee per episode how would you
go about calculating the minimum maximum
mean number of episodes per season so
I'll give you a minute to think about
that and then I'll come back up here to
where
where was it that we got the mean min
max ah there we go so I'll put this down
here or you may find that as a useful
guide
I'll give you another minute here yeah
contradicting powers too
I have not used so the question here is
how does this sequel methods or function
within data world work compared to oh oh
ah I don't know I I used I use pandas
pretty exclusively as anyone here know
whether how they compare or is it mixed
up and what kind of operation you're
doing okay
so in this case we were counting
essentially the number of unique IDs
associated and we reach IDs and is it is
an identifier for a different script
line after grouping by episodes where
we're going to allow group by this time
okay we're going to group by season so
we're going to replace episode with
season and then within each season what
is the thing that we want to know the
number unique values for episode ID
okay so the small number of episodes in
a season was 13 the highest was 25 and
the average is close to 22 and then
honestly at this point it's a fairly
straightforward copy and paste operation
here to plot the distribution
oops there we'll just plug a hist at the
end of that and we get our plot
all right one more pair of exercises
along this vein what are the minimum
maximum mean number of characters
appearing per episode
now assuming this one is even more
straightforward
oops
what are we going to group by this time
we're going to group by episode ID and
then what is the thing we care about
here it could be one of two things right
there's two different fields that are
focused on characters can use character
ID or what else we use
walk character text right because
there's a somewhere in this notebook I
kind of sketched that a little bit
further there is a there are sometimes
several character text values associated
with the unique character ID okay it
doesn't seem to have much effect on the
overall distribution of data though and
then just around things out
we can plot that distribution as well to
get a sense for the number of characters
that appear on average per episode
question okay what I was finding as I
was going along and preparing some
exercises for this is some of the more
interesting questions that arose were
things more about the characters then
say the script lines with the episodes
there's really things about you know how
often do people appear and so on and
what I found is I kept on rerunning
these these pandas operations to group
and select and do all these things and
what I really want to do is have a data
frame that was on that I could use to to
to manipulate and so I put together a
set of exercises here and I think I'll
run through these a little bit more
quickly because they're not really so
much to do with analysis as much as
constructing a data frame for subsequent
analysis so but I found it kind of a
useful set of tricks of it or techniques
that you might find generally useful so
we're going to put together a data frame
that is going to have the the number of
line up that this can have information
on a per character basis rather than a
per script line or a per episode basis
so the idea is each row is going to
represent a different character okay and
one thing out here we go
so one thing to point out here is a
number of raw character texts is
different from the number of character
IDs okay and we can get a sense for what
that looks like if we group by the
character ID and then we instead of
taking n unique we actually take use the
unique function which returns a list of
the unique values within a group okay
and here you can see for example
that for a character ID one we have
Marge Simpson but we also have young
Marge Marge asazin and so on just to
give you a sense for what the different
character text that might be associated
with a single ID look like okay so I
think it's useful to be able to create a
table you know to have this group by we
have an entry level role for each
character text and then we can still
regroup by the character ID if we only
want to use character ID but we at least
have a full set of information not to
worry about lists of values in certain
cells we can we can keep things simpler
in that regard okay so what we're going
to do then is we are going to create
something where we have a character ID
or raw character text and then just to
get started a column indicating the
number of script lines associated with
each raw character text okay and the way
we're going to do that is we're going to
group by in this case two things we're
going to first group by character ID and
then secondarily by raw character ID
text so now each group will have will
share a single ID and ashing and single
text will have more groups than we would
if we didn't if we only group by ID okay
and so what you see there is we get the
we get the rows that we're looking for
including the null character essentially
the character that has a magan verb can
immediately ignore the speaking lines
and other complications here okay so and
again so I actually created this one
before I create the other self exercise
so I'm duplicating myself here but this
isn't tactically identical okay so what
we did up here is we are not discussed
intact we identify oh I something
tactically identical but it's
functionally identical right we take the
size of each group but if we also just
count the number of unique IDs we
essentially because we know the ID
values are unique for every script line
we get the same result and then I'll
also note that here I'm inserting a
reset index just to pull things down
from a multi index into a single data
frame
because
I get all balled up when I try use multi
indexes I try to convert them back data
frames as soon as I can okay so if we do
this operation here let's see here I
guess I will pull this down so it's all
visible okay so now if we group by
character ID raw character text and then
count the number of unique IDs we set
the index whoops let's see here we can
then rename the columns because as you
can see here what we end up with is
because we're selecting the ID this is
kinda mean like we're getting a column
called ID which is not very helpful in
fact it's even misleading given what the
what the value represents and so what
we're going to do is we're going to
rename the column called ID to num lines
which is a number which is actually the
thing we're counting and then we're
going to assign that value to a new data
frame we'll call DF characters oops and
then let's see what that looks like okay
so looks pretty much like the other ones
except we now have a column named num
lines and we've stored the result in a
data frame
and then if we want to find out who has
the most lines we can use these sort
values function on a data frame pass it
in the the thing we want to sort on and
then say show it show it to us in
descending order so surprise surprise
Homer Simpson has the most lines of the
null character has the second most lines
it turns out Homer has twice as many
lines as Marge and in fact if you go
follow the links to the the original
blog post one of the things they were
looking at is gender distribution in the
frequency with which you know different
characters had numbers of lines and so
on but but I'll leave that as an
exercise beyond what we're going to do
here okay if we want to exclude that
let's see here plus all into one at all
yes okay so we could also using a
similar technique we used before is we
constrain the rows that are returned to
only those rows for which the character
ID is greater than zero or alternatively
equivalently the raw character text is
not the empty string okay and we get you
find out that Milhouse is the tenth most
high and say for both personally the
most lines in the seasons here okay so
um
triose I hear we're on a time here I
think just for the just for the moment
we'll try this first exercise I mean
kind of raced through the others I think
once you get the first one the rest will
become clear but I sometimes get all
balled up using merge effectively and
pulling things together so now that we
have a data frame with D F characters
that shows the number of lines for each
character how do we go about adding a
column that counts the number of
episodes in which each character appears
okay so now I'll do a few minutes to try
to work on this and then we'll go ahead
to the answer you might find it useful
to break this down into two steps in the
first step you might create a new data
frame that contains the number of
episode ID values associates raw
character text and you might also use
you know some techniques we used before
and then merge that into the F character
so now instead of having a separate data
frame where you have a new you know an
entry for each Rock header text and a
number of episodes you actually have a
single data frame VF character look has
number of lines and number of episodes
so I'll give you a minute to think about
that and work on that a little bit
this is also in the answers and that I
have a whole function that will pull
this all together if we if we go to
tired of it
how many people figure it out and say do
not matter to
how many people figured out how to do
the creating out another data frame part
okay how many who would like a little
more time okay
you
all right so step one is to create your
data frame where we can have the number
of episode you values with each raw
character text values so based on the
earlier example we're probably going to
create some groups right and what we're
going to route by in this case raw
character text so we're going to say
group by and then what we care about
though is the number of unique episode
ID values associated with each of those
groups okay so how are we going to
figure that out
going out to here
and then and unique and then just keep
it all readable oh actually well yeah
Dec so what that shows you is a multi
index object that has the values that we
care about jump stamp the ticket man
occurred in five episodes interesting
okay and so as I said I generally try to
get out of multi index land as soon as I
can when this kind of thing occurs so
I'm going to say reset in index and then
we go from a multi index back to a data
frame yes
yes except that I already found out that
I know I know for a fact that any raw
character text is exactly is associated
exactly one but you're right I would
definitely want to group by both of
those so I can be sure them but in this
case we're safe okay so data frame now
we want to merge it in with the existing
data frame which we're calling DF
characters so we'll say DF characters
merge and then we're going to merge
something into it and essentially we're
going to merge into it is that data
frame we just created so we could size
it to a variable DF temp or whatever but
I'm just going to it's really just a
throw away so I'm just going to grab
this well here's what I should do also I
should show you that okay there are six
thousand seven hundred sixty four rows
in this data frame and just to be safe
we're the same number of rows your time
so we're going to merge
this data frame can you see if I can add
a few get rid of the head whoops okay so
we're going to merge the data frame
created by this group by operation we
just did and what we're going to merge
on raw character text we know they have
the same amount of values but I
generally default to using left as a as
a as a mainstay
okay so that gives me a new column and
when standing wrong with that column
yeah it's called episode ID will be a
better name for it nah Memphis ODEs all
right so let's grab this and call
renamed again and columns equals episode
ID : num episodes oops
that's all it that's a dictionary
okay so now I've got the new a new
merged data frame and the only thing I
need to do now is to make it the new
value of DF characters I don't think
there's in place for merges or I don't
think any help last I looked there
wasn't so now I'm going to grab
everything but the head there are a
number of times where I've forgotten to
lop off the head and I end up having a
very small new data frame and having to
rerun all the cells
so that's happen enough time so I'm very
careful about that kind of thing usually
let's see if I do it here okay so now
I'm going to say DF characters equals
that and just to make sure
DF characters has the desired fields
questions
this is a useful exercise yes so the
question is why does it end up with
episode ID as the column name to begin
with I think it has to do when I reset
the index to just pull it down but
that's a good question I don't know why
it does that ah okay okay don't know if
you heard that this so the Alex just
explained that when you do an
aggregation of the default to just
assume what if you don't seem calm you
just grab the name of column that you're
a great down that's a good question does
anyone know just so question is it's a
way to do renaming right when the during
the grouping right or great during the
end unique yeah so before I do the reset
index here I could rename here using the
same method rename ah
okay let's see what it looks like so the
suggestion is here we say rename and
like that whoops oh right right
okay I'm not going to run everything now
with all but but but takes for that tip
now actually I'll try it the next time
around because we have other exercises
like this yes oh ah okay so let me okay
so another way of doing this and it's
not going to work of course because of
the fact we already have a value here
believes it is instead of renaming this
way we could pass in a parameter here
like that are my parentheses
okay cool thank you I get to learn some
stuff other questions or comments okay
let's do one more exercise and then
we'll just kind of race through because
the others are pretty easy and we can
just run the actual utility function to
do it just so we have some time for
questions at the end
oh mike is actually one more thing about
even time series analysis actually yeah
I forgot that we haven't even gotten to
the next two seconds if so what I'm
going to say for now is you can work out
the other exercises on your own and/or
look at their results there but if you
just call this cell right here you can
use the solution that I created in the
PI data under source Simpsons module the
PI file in the repository and it will
it'll take care of all those things okay
so when you run that you should end up
with something that looks like this
where you have the number of nine number
of episodes first episode and last
episode IDs the number of seasons and
the first and last season anyone not
have that okay
okay so let's there just two more sets
of exercise here one is just a quick one
now that we have a data frame for each
character can you figure out the minimum
maximum mean number of script lines for
each character actually who's that
and using the data for the DF characters
data frame
and because we're going short time I'm
just going to put this in here where you
the same whoops something to colorizer
okay and then there's other things you
could do about you know first and last
and num sees and so on but having
aggregated everything together and data
frame makes it easier to ask certain
kinds of questions now questions on VF
characters okay
so we're finally at the section that was
advertised in the in the abstract which
is unevenly spaced time series analysis
and what's different about this kind of
analysis than most time series analysis
that what really matters is the
intervals
it's the gaps between things over time
that that turns out to be the case so I
end up doing this occasionally but not
so often that I forget which is sort of
main motivation here so examples of what
we've done it indeed
so just indeed has a new organization
called indeed hire how many people have
heard of indeed before oh good
okay so indeed is a is the world's
biggest job search engine we have tens
of millions of jobs we have tens of
millions of resumes and and what we
basically do is we try to match them up
somehow either for employers or for
jobseekers we have a new business called
indeed hire where we have recruiters we
have a team of recruiters that will make
those placements which is a great
because a lot of times indeed we try to
figure out how we look at the day
overtime apparel how'd that get there
why is that looked like that and now we
can actually talk to people who work for
indeed and figured out why they do the
things they do so one things we be
looking at of things like how often do
we have repeat business from existing
clients and then we often look at that
to see the intervals between the dates
on which a new job requisition was
created and then because we have
different ways of finding it sometimes a
client will start up a new job within a
day or two of starting of giving us one
and that's not counting but then how far
out you go you go week a month and so on
so you know these being able to kind of
look for the intervals was actually
important there and the other kind of
thing I end up doing sometimes is look
when our recruiters review profiles we
try to figure out well how much time is
that take you how much time are they
spending actually dis positioning
profiles and some of them are very
absent spends with jobs of course so
looking for the time intervals between
each disposition state change during
profile review is one way to try to get
a sense for that and then of course we
have to tease out things like where does
the session end and so on all that said
rather than try to try out a bunch and
having to explain a whole bunch of the
indeed data will stick with the Simpsons
data and so and we'll look for scene
changes and I don't know quite how to
find scene changes per se but one way
that we might approximate it is to look
at well if you've got at a new location
right is one way you might look at it's
probably going to have some noise in
there too but because sometimes it goes
back and forth quickly but that might be
one way to do it so it turns out there
are four hundred and seven rows in our
original data frame where the location
ID is zero fortunately those are also
the ones where the wall location text is
empty and they happen and they all
they'll co-occur with each other ok so
just you know again there's some noise
they're still so noisy that even though
we clean up a bunch of things and okay
so here are some examples of of lines
where there is no location okay and we
could go in and try to look for some
ways of interpolating this in fact I
started down this path in this separate
notebook of data cleaning but turns out
a lot of these things are you know so
many things weeks are due to just you
know munged up quotation marks in the
original CSV file so even interpolation
may not be a good way of handling it so
with it with that understood well it
whoops you so hear me good so it's also
the case just like there are there are
some location IDs that have some
character ideas that have multiple
locations to the character text values
there are also location IDs that have
multiple location text values okay and
that one of the things is that they're
not all lowercase they're not all
normalized is one reason but there's
other ways referring to the same thing
okay so there are some of the most
frequently occurring locations the
Simpson home the the school the tavern
and so on and then at the other end of
the spectrum we can look at some of the
in frequently occurring location Rock
row location text values as well and you
can see there that we have a mix of all
uppercase and mixed case as well okay so
how many people have used the shift
function in pandas before okay this is
actually something that Annette
introduced to me when I was struggling
with banging my head against trying to
figure out how to do some of these
analyses earlier I said oh if you tried
shift it's like oh no okay so on one way
that we might identify location changes
is look for changes where the location
of the current script line is different
from the location of the previous script
line okay
so again we'll look at just the the
first few rows of our data show that the
locations are one and then there's four
lines associated location to okay if we
apply shift to the location what that
does is it shifts everything down one so
this one now shows up in the second row
of the shifted series okay so we get a
one there and then these three twos show
up here on rows 2 3 & 4 instead of being
on rows 1 2 & 3 and then because there
was nothing
by definition before row 0 that's a null
value okay and then just to you know we
could also shift up so by first I show
you more than Phi there but now you can
see that by using shift minus 1 you can
shift things in the opposite direction
and you can do more than one values and
you can actually shift by time
for date time and all kinds of time
offsets there's lots of it's a very
powerful function but we're not going to
go into all that here because we already
had everything organized the rows and
I'll really care about this shifting
things a little bit okay so first we
will group by episodes and looks like I
must have done this later I'll try to be
consistent internally here so if we
first group by the episode and then we
take the location ID field and we shift
it whoops oh I forgot to put a period
back in okay so it turns out because we
had previously already sorted the data
frame based on IDs all five of the first
lines in the script are essentially from
the first episode so we get the same
value so what we can do here though is
again because I like working with intz
this only works because there is no
location zero if it was a zero based
indexing system then this would not work
but because it is a one baited the
numbering starts at one then we can
count count zero is no values we can
essentially do the shift we can use
philan a philan l values with zero and
encourage everything to in 64 okay so
now we get a filled with infinite with
zero substituted for the null values and
then we can add that into the main data
frame by essentially referencing a new
column name with the value of let's see
here just so it all shows up on the
screen of that last thing the last line
and then i won't show you the full data
frame but there you can see that
everything's kind of shifted down one
okay so now if we went through it
whenever the location and the location
ID and the previous location ID values
don't match we've got a scene change
more or less I mean I'm conveniently
forgetting the fact that
have one two zeros with four and seven
roads right where there's a script line
there's a zero location but again from
the moment would immediately forget that
okay so final exercise
oh sorry do it well isn't that
convenient okay so how many scene
changes are there across all episodes
what we can do is just take the we can
constrain the data frame looking for the
roads where the location ID and the
previous location ID are not the same
and then just take the length of the
resulting data frame okay so it looks
like over the course of the history
there are seventeen thousand or so scene
changes and just to kind of double-check
whenever I do something like that I kind
of like to see well what's what's the
flip side of that what are what are the
number of rows where they are the same
and that should be a high number and
unfortunately it is so I guess it was in
way fortunate and that my intention was
to end by 11:45 so that there be time
for questions comments or in the or
really lunch line so that's the end of
the notebook I'll stop there and open up
to any questions yes if you do this well
you use like a window function to ship
things part of that is improving by
location and then choosing I can order
by weird I think by default is isn't
ordering by whatever it is it's already
sorted by is there any way to specify
how you want it ordered when you're
shifting that's a good so I'm sorry you
want to be able to change the order of
the shift or in case your data set is
really not sorted oh properly I think
that is there laying within
shifting itself to tell it how you want
it order when you're going one back or
forward I'm not aware of one I would
probably sort the head of time either in
serving the day or frame or apply sort
operator somewhere along the line in the
chain calls question over there so the
question is what do you do when you have
big data instead of small to medium
sized data like this data set are you
asking specifically about the shift
operator or in general yeah that's a
that's a good question I so far I
haven't tried to apply this on a dataset
that's more than say a million records
which is still you know at most medium
so I haven't exhausted memory or other
kinds of problems so I haven't accounted
as anyone have any suggestions generally
for how to deal with that ah - all right
in Tara there's a - tutorial later today
right ah okay so that might be a good
question to address there other
questions yes hi thanks this is this was
a fun tutorial with The Simpsons
application question about the final
output of like your two examples with
indeed or the Simpsons so now that you
have neither you somehow kind of made
consistent these uneven spaces how do
you how do you show the time series or
how's that applied so in the example of
where I was looking for the gaps between
new requisitions from the same client
what I actually was using was not
integer like orderings but actual date
time values so I essentially had the
dates of these things then I could use
the pandas ways of manipulating offsets
and count the number of days and then
you know divide that by seven if I
wanted weeks or other kinds of
mechanisms to try to get a sense for for
that
okay so the the final output of this
analysis is a essentially like a metric
that you're looking at not like a not a
time series yes so in this particular
case what we were trying to find is
count the number of of distinct
requisitions that represent repeat
business versus new business and so what
the key was was trying to filter out the
when we have more than one requisition
they occurred too close to the first
requisition we want to discount them and
then different people had different
ideas about what that should look like
so we want to see how the overall counts
would be affected for sales numbers
thank you other questions yes yep yeah
so the question is for let's see if I
can find it here why was I using the
loke function rather than just the
bracketed way of referencing columns in
right here
the reason is I've just gotten into this
habit I don't know if I need to here but
I keep paying these warning messages
whenever I do these assignments just
using the old way of bracketing things
because it's either a copy or a panel or
a view and so I've just got into the
habit of referencing things via the
location when I'm using labels versus
positional references I don't know if
it's necessary here it's just it's just
a habit I've gotten into other questions
all right thanks don't forget we're
raffling off for drones stop by the
indeed booth and if anyone's interested
in working at indeed please come see me
or any of my distinguished colleagues
here thanks
[Applause]